[Musik]
guten tag seit 150 jahren gilt in der
römisch katholischen kirche das dogma
der päpstlichen unfehlbarkeit nach
diesem dogma als der papst dann
unfehlbar wenn er etwas extra das heißt
die übung ausübung seines obersten
lehramtes eine glaubens oder sitten
frage für die ganze kirche endgültig
entscheidet und seit bestehen dieses
dogma es wird heftig darüber gestritten
einer der prominentesten kritiker war
der vor kurzem verstorbene schweizer
theologe hans küng
1994 hat können in dieser sendung seine
kritik erläutert wie kommt es eigentlich
dass wir ein system haben
wo also in einer form die es ja sonst
auf der erde gar nicht mehr gibt ein
einziger da oben meint er könnte
unfehlbar entscheiden das eben in dieser
frage das so und so zu sein hat und
nicht anders und das da komme ich eben
wieder auf das zurück dass man das nur
dann versteht wenn man die ganze
geschichte etwa wie sich dieses ganze
römische systementwicklung wenn man das
halt mal anschaut und viele katholiken
sind sich darüber überhaupt nicht im
klaren die meinen jahre passat schon
immer der papst und der hat dieses recht
nein es wird dann sogar deutlich dass
sich dieses wirklich für die kirche
schädliche römische system seit dem
elften jahrhundert herausgebildet hat
ich habe das bis ins letzte analysiert
was damit verbunden war und wir sind
einfach noch im mittelalter stecken
geblieben und haben noch nachdem also
selbst der kommunismus nicht mehr eine
generalsekretär hat der test bestimmen
kann sind wir noch die einzigen die in
einer mittelalterlichen gegen
reformatorischen antimodernen weise ein
system haben wo nun wirklich einer in
solchen fragen nun seine meinung gegen
die ganze welt setzen kann
ich bin ja nicht gehen ein paar sorgen
aber ich bin entschieden gerade aufgrund
dieser historischen analyse gegen ein
system das auf einen absoluten monarchen
hat in einem system das ich auch selber
immer reproduziert wieder also da ist
glaube ich eine der entscheidenden
anfang die ich heute
an diese verfassung stellen muss also
wir können wenn wir nicht so
weitermachen wie das bisher gewesen ist
und wir müssen diese geschichte die sich
da so langsam langsam entwickelt hat von
einem solchen bedingt vorjahren system
ist also ein diktatorisches system also
da müssen wir dagegen angehen und ich
möchte nur hoffen dass das auch die
bischöfe währung mehr verstehen
um diese aussagen zu diskutieren und
fürs heute einzuordnen sitzt judith
wipfler bei mir ihre stimme hören sie
sonst im radio des theologen und meine
kolleginnen der fachredaktion religion
schön dass du hier bist vielen dank gern
1970 hat hans kühn ja in einer bereits
in einer schrift dieser unfehlbarkeit
angezweifelt beziehungsweise infrage
gestellt ich habe mich gefragt weshalb
er denn genau dieses unfehlbarkeit dogma
ins visier genommen hat weil es ja schon
eine sehr geringer wirkungsgeschichte
hatte es wurde erst einmal wirklich
angewandt
also ich denke es war auch eine art
symbol oder kulminationspunkt für den
papiss muss wenn wir jetzt polemisch
sprechen wollen und der hat eben seinen
höhepunkt benommen 78 mit diesem ersten
vatikanischen konzil als dieses
unfehlbarkeit dogma erlassen wurde und
ich darum geht es ihnen denke ich 1970
und auch nachher war gerade das zweite
vatikanische konzil knapp vorbei die
moderne hatte angefangen für die
römisch-katholische kirche hans küng ein
ganz hoffnungsfroh theologe dann hoffte
jetzt geht es voran
und dann kommen gleich wieder dämpfer 68
die pillen enzyklika die wieder genau
gegen alles war also durch die
selbstbestimmung nach dem eigenen
gewissen zum beispiel das war ja auch
etwas was mit dem zweiten vatikanum dazu
gekommen ist
es wurde ihm ja dann eben auch die
lehrerlaubnis entzogen 79 also ein paar
jahre nach dieser schrift aber unter
anderem deswegen das hat mich auch
erstaunt weil im grunde genommen doch
dieses dogma zu den umstrittensten
beschlüssen überhaupt zählt ja aber doch
mal war daneben dogma und das ist dann
eine wahrheit die dann gilt in der
römisch-katholischen kirche und sie
wurde dann auch durchgezogen
justament natürlich von johannes paul im
zweiten dessen ära genau dann quasi auch
begann mit der dieser leer verurteilung
für hans kühn und dann folgten über 20
jahre für progressive theologinnen und
theologen in der römisch katholischen
kirche
jetzt spricht im einspieler
ich habe es mir aufgeschrieben er
spricht das system anders spricht von
anti modernität er spricht von
diktatorischen zuständen und davon dass
das eben seit dem schädlichen römischen
system des elften jahrhunderts sich
herausgebildet habe um jetzt diese
kritik von können einordnen zu können um
sie überhaupt zu verstehen muss man sie
auch so ein bisschen im horizont eben
der entstehung dieses dogmas während des
ersten vatikanischen konzils verstehen
da ist das stichwort für mich der anti
modernismus das neunzehnte jahrhundert
da kam die naturwissenschaften auf da
kam die kritische philosophie auf auch
der protestantismus hat in dieser zeit
schwer zu kämpfen gehabt sich gegen
säkularismus durchzusetzen
schleiermacher antwortet darauf hat er
versucht darauf antworten zu geben und
in dieser zeit hat sich die römisch
katholische kirche dann quasi wie
nochmal zugemauert mit mit so einem
dogma das eigentlich schon damals nicht
zeitgemäß gewesen ist
hans küng war zu beginn seiner karriere
auch theologischer berater während des
zweiten vatikanischen konzils dort wurde
als ergänzung zum ersten vatikanischen
konzil und dem primat des papstes das
bischofs kollegium aufgewertet und küng
sah die errungenschaften dieses konzils
aber verraten wir 2003 und 2005 in den
sternstunden erklärte kollegial heißt
dass das was das zweite vatikanische
konzil beschlossen hat einfach jetzt
formiert oder in fordern von irgend
jemandem es ist feierlich beschlossen
worden
gegen diesen päpstlichen absolutismus
triumphalismus juli des salons das was
man kritisiert hat dass der papst sich
um petrus in einem kollegium operieren
soll und nicht absolutistisch allein da
oben was jetzt wieder dargestellt hatte
ganze zeit man hat angenommen dass der
papst nach dem nach dem konzil mit dem
bischofsrat zusammen das macht dass man
gemeinsam diskutiert beschlüsse fasst
dass der papst sicher ein vetorecht hat
aber von all dem ist nichts geblieben
wir haben die kirche nicht richtig
reformieren können weil wir das papsttum
nicht reformiert haben weil die
kirchenverfassung immer noch
absolutistisch ist wie damals obwohl die
bischöfe kollegialität beschlossen hat
die große enttäuschung kam ja im grunde
ist nach dem konzil wo sich die höhe
juli nicht mehr dran gehalten hat es ist
natürlich interessant dass kings
lehrerlaubnis hinzu quasi genau das
zeigt was er ja auch kritisiert nämlich
den zentralismus
das heißt wer nicht pariert wird
letztlich von rom suspendiert ja ich
denke jetzt im moment wird ein bisschen
ein anderer wind und vielleicht hat
können da ja auch etwas dazu beigetragen
dass so exakt beschrieben zu haben
ich erinnere noch mal an den erfolg
denen auch können gehabt hat mit seinen
thesen weit über den katholizismus
hinaus er war einer der ja die ökumene
schon in den 50er jahren wo hin dachte
wir heute gar nicht mehr sind also da
ist denke ich doch viel noch da von der
kritik von kühen auf der im moment
aufgebaut wird gerade die kollegialität
der bischöfe die auch eben noch mal
angesprochen hat die sehe ich jetzt doch
auf einem guten weg indem immer häufiger
auch bischof synoden einberufen werden
die thematisch was erarbeiten und
stepper papst sich das dann der heutige
papst sich das dann auch zu herzen nimmt
was was aus dem kollegium der welt
bischöfe herauskommt ja das mit der
ökumene scheint mir auch ganz wichtig
das hat ja eigentlich gewissermaßen
schon mit seiner dissertation begonnen
was ihnen dann auch auf den rat des
vatikans gebracht hat aber er sagt
trotzdem das war 2003 das eine beispiel
dass wir gesehen haben dass die kirchen
fassung noch immer absolutistisch sei
wenn wir jetzt eben aufs heute schauen
wie du es schon gemacht gemacht hast
dann betont franziskus hat die
ortskirchen und er sagt auch in der
leitung der gesamtkirche müsse man die
ortskirchen berücksichtigen
das klingt für mich zuerst mal nach der
zentralisierung würdest du eben sagen
das diese dezentralisierung über
diese tendenz auch auf küng zurück geht
ich denke auf die bewegung zu der könig
gehört hat und schlussendlich ist es ja
auch teil der konstitution der
römisch-katholischen kirche es gibt die
möglichkeit ein konzil das ist eine
bischofs versammlung einzuberufen die
dann auch wahrheit glaubenswahrheit
erkennt und es gibt auch ganz stark im
zweiten vatikanum hans küng hat sogar
angesprochen
immer wieder dass dieses kirchen volk
oder volk gottes wie es dann in dieser
sprache heißt durchaus auch in der lage
ist die wahrheit des glaubens zu
erkennen und das die aus erkennen können
was für leichter papst selber noch nicht
erkannt hat und das hat franziskus
wirklich auch so gesagt und gesagt
schreibt mir sagt mir wie ihr glauben
lebt wie ihr kirche erlebt und da ist ja
vielleicht eher noch von der
befreiungstheologie südamerikas und dem
basis kirchen bewegungen geprägt als
denn jetzt direkt von hans küng
das klingt ja nach einer linearen
entwicklung trotzdem gab es ja
rückschritte diverse genau und die gibt
es auch immer wieder
man hat manchmal den eindruck bei
franziskus er weiß noch nicht so richtig
wie er sich durchsetzt er konnte einfach
sagen er redet als kathedra also er
wendet quasi das dogma an
aber das will ja nicht er will eben
genau den diskurs er will die
kollegialität der bischöfe und er will
hören was die menschen an der basis
glauben und leben jetzt ist es ja so
dass das können auch sagt kirchenreform
und papst reform gehen hand in hand die
dortmund kann man aber in dem sinne
nicht zurück in das es vorher auch schon
angedeutet wie würdest du denn sagen
sind die reformen trotzdem in diesen
großen schritten auch möglich die heute
eingefordert werden
das ist das grundproblem denke ich der
der römisch katholischen kirche
wenn ein dogma also eine
glaubenswahrheit weisheit wahrheit
einmal erkannt wurde
dann kann man sie nicht mehr
zurücknehmen vielleicht kommen ja neue
oder andere glaubenswahrheiten sie sind
nie neue der römisch-katholischen leser
sie werden einfach erkannt vielleicht
erkennt die römisch katholische kirche
ja dann auch noch mal andere daumens
wahrheiten so ein aktives verfahren
wäre doch vielleicht eine idee und ich
denke daher will der durch jetzige papst
franziskus durchaus auch hin
eine entwicklung die der tradition
genüge tut und allen flügeln in seiner
kirche
auch hilft wie steht denn das franziskus
selbst zum unfehlbarkeit stockmann hat
er sich dazu geäußert in mir fällt jetzt
keine explizite aussage dazu ein
aber er hat sich ja verschiedentlich
eben zurück genommen also diese aussage
gegenüber einem homosexuellen menschen
wer wenig zu urteilen über die art und
weise wie mein bruder da lebt das zeigt
ja auch da tritt er nicht als experte da
auf sondern eher als seelsorger und
jemand der die kirche einen will das hat
er ja auch ganz stark gezeigt eben auch
bei seiner einsetzung und so mancher
bilder war quasi einer unter vielen ist
ich möchte trotzdem noch einen punkt
hervorheben trotz dieser ganzen kritik
die man gewissermaßen amt an diesem
primat des papstes haben kann hat es ja
auch positive züge wenn man bedenkt dass
es über nationen hinweg da ein garant
für einheit gibt im vatikan statt
das wird auch immer so hervorgehoben
dass dass dieser erste unter vielen die
alle zusammen halten soll
es ist glaube ich auch eine frage wie
ein papst sein abend letztendlich selber
versteht also versteht er sich eher als
hirte als pontifex als brückenbauer als
einer oder versteht er sich als jemand
dem quasi der heilige geist direkt die
glaubenswahrheit eingibt und kanada max
katheter verbreiten ja also das ist ja
beides möglich und ich denke es gibt
möglichkeiten für veränderung in der
römisch katholischen kirche soll die
frage werden diese möglichkeiten
ergriffen gibt es sowas wie ein größeres
vermächtnis von können was würdest du
sagen judith also ich für mich ist er
stark eine große figur des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
dort hat er gelebt und hat auch die
menschen direkt angesprochen hat und das
richtige wort zur richtigen zeit gesagt
und seine bücher haben wir unglaubliche
auflagen erfahren dass millionenauflagen
muss man sagen weltweit welche theologe
welche theologin schafft das heute
überhaupt noch
ich denke diese zeiten sind vielleicht
auch erst mal vorbei aber so wird er
auch in erinnerung bleiben also auch als
ständiger mahner und das zweite was von
ihm bleibt ist diese öffnung zum
interreligiösen dialog für den frieden
das windfeld das was wirklich in unserer
gegenwart immer noch passt mehr hin
leben dank judith für das gespräch jetzt
gleich geht es darum wie das
zusammenleben gelingt wenn wir die
gemeinsame sprache verlieren meine
kollegin barbara bleisch spricht mit der
kulturwissenschaftlerin mit genialen
über die schwierigkeit wir zu sagen und
darüber da die deutungshoheit über die
eigene identität hat ihnen wünsche ich
einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]